there's little reason to fierce
videogames will cause a catastrophic
labor shortage first of all it's a red
flag that the big gasp in hours
unemployment between younger and older
men emerge during the Great Recession
and not-so-great recovery they're
playing potential non-gaming
explanations for instance during a time
of economic unrest employers may have
demanded more education and experience
from potential employee moreover if the
recession recovery played a big role in
young men working less then work rates
should improve the further remove in
this economic expansion and guess what
that's exactly what seem to be happening
it's also unclear what role video games
play in long-term employment trends for
young men since 2000 the
employment-to-population ratio has
fallen by about 10 percentage points in
the United States but in Japan where
presumably they play a lot of video
games the work ratios actually increased
a bit over that same span the big
problem with the u.s. economy over the
past decades is in gaming any more than
its automation or trade it's the fact
that Americans suffered a massive
financial shock and near depression and
it just takes a while for economies to
recover do you think video games keep
young men from working let us know in
your comment also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI